We love Halloween.
You got a problem, lady?
This obsessive need to be dark and scary.
You can't even stop yourself.
AAAhh.
Oh. Hi, honey. Breakfast will be ready in a
minute.
AAaah! My hand.
Very funny, mom.
I know it's Halloween.
Nice fake hand.
Ah ha ha ha ha.
We love Halloween, especially Claire.
It's my favorite holiday.
Ever since I was a kid, I loved scary
things. If there was a new horror movie in
town, I was the first in line.
One, please.
Then I met Phil.
Two please.
Every Halloween we have the best house.
Last year I took things to a whole new
level. But, apparently it was too scary for
some kids and one adult.
Trick or treat.
Would you like some candy?
Yeah. Or would you rather have this?
Come on, you're fine.
I don't care what anyone says.
You did not give that man a heart attack.
Thank you. I mean.
You're not even scary.
Can I grab a little bit of this candy for my
open house tonight?
Yeah, sure.
But it's genius.
An open house on Halloween.
Millions of bored parents just trying to
keep their kids out of traffic.
Now they can get away from all that and see
a nice house.
What do you mean? I'm not even scary?
I literally almost scared the life out of a
man.
You literally scared a little saliva and a
little urine out of him. That happens to me
every time I see a monkey wearing people
clothes.
I was plenty scary.
I used professional grade makeup.
That's the point, Claire.
It was overkill.
You're the kind of person who can be twice
as scary without wearing any makeup.
Bye.
Oh, no, no.
This doesn't look real at all.
Alex. Where's that blood you were using this
morning? On your finger.
Running through my veins, keeping me alive?
Oh, here comes dad.
He's going to be all like, no.
What did you do? Where's Awesomeland.
No. What did you
do? Where's Awesomeland?
Are you from the future?
Phil, honey, honey, we've had a little change
of plans. Why?
What are you even doing here? Shouldn't you
be at work?
That obnoxious Ronnie was worried that I
wouldn't be able to handle his decorations.
Because he's trying to win this scariest
house on the street contest, and I was like,
not only can I handle your decorations, I'm
going to win that contest.
So welcome to the insane asylum from hell.
That's what it feels like.
Come on. It's going to be fun.
The kids are going to be deranged mental
patients, and I am going to be a sadistic
nurse. And you are a demented doctor.
20 years of no.
But for this, you'll dress like a nurse.
Oh, no. Come on. Oh, of course, the woman is
the nurse and the man is the doctor.
That kind of thinking, that's what's scary.
Tap out. It's a holiday day.
You know, I put a lot of time and energy into
my thing, but you just shut it all down to
prove something to people that we barely
know and don't even like.
Phil.
Ronnie made fun of Awesomeland.
He called it Candyland.
So? Stupidville.
Dumburge.
Who cares what he thinks?
Maybe someday you'll care what I think.
Phil. Well, honey, look, I kept your bunny.
Nibbles!
Monster,
do my bidding.
I do as you command, master.
Okay, mom, you cannot have a problem with
this. I'm Mother Teresa.
Are you kidding me? What?
I'm her back when she was hot.
I will pay you $10 to go put on more clothes.
Bet it's the first time you ever heard that
one. Okay, you know what?
Let's. Here we go.
Let's just cover you up, all right?
Now, I just want to run through this really
quick with everybody.
First, it's trick or treat, and then Phil..
Come
in if you dare.
Right. And then dad does the thunder and the
lightning and the fog usher the children in
past Alex in her cage.
I'm in a cage?
Yes. You're in a house of horrors.
Being held against your will.
Yeah, I know, so why do we need the cage?
And then Gloria pops up as the evil village
bruja. And she says, Welcome
to your nightmare
ah-ha ha! Then Cam and Haley do their thing.
Kids get their candy, they are ushered out.
They think it's all over.
But it's not. Because out on the porch, the
scarecrow pops to life.
Wow. For one final.
And that's Mitchell. You're the scarecrow.
Oh, no. No, I was in a costume all day.
It was awful.
It's nothing compared to when I was.
You don't own bad Halloweens.
Don't I?
We get it, Cam. Hard day.
Mitchell, please. The costumes in the
kitchen. Come on.
Claire. Claire.
Before you go, I just want you to know I love
you more.
That's okay. Okay.
Thanks, honey. You're my best friend.
You really think it's appropriate to be
strapping your teenage daughter to a gurney?
If we win, it is.
I may have to take a pee break soon.
Oh, here, use this bedpan.
I'm kidding. That's gross.
I put candy in it here.
Luke. Luke.
I think I fell asleep.
This thing is like a Temple Grandin hug.
Haley, sweetie.
Gowns on backwards.
Oh, no. It's cuter this way.
Sexy people go crazy to, you know, read a
people magazine.
Huh?
Phil, you're not even going to try on your
doctor costume.
Nope. But we're going to win.
Does that make you happy?
Do I look happy?
You got a problem, lady?
This obsessive need to be dark and scary.
You can't even stop yourself.
I can stop whenever I want.
Well, I'm not getting sucked in.
I'm having the Halloween that I wanted.
I'll fill you in at the staff meeting after
Kennealy is done telling us about his
morning commute.
That's hilarious.
You sound just like him.
You are so doing that at Christmas talent
night. Dude. Rich girl.
Sara. Smile.
Then a man eater encore, was scary how good
they were. Close your eyes, it could have
been the real band.
Yeah. You got lucky in the football pool
once, and now he wants to double the stakes.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Right? Well, this night was a bust.
Not a single person even.
Or did I speak too soon?
Was someone in the mood to be a bad little
ghoul? Oh, Connie, I didn't mean you.
I'm. Hey, that's just.
That's just the divorce talking.
Hang in there. Bye bye.
Who is it? Special delivery from UPS.
United Prank Service.
I went to the history books for this one.
All the way back to the first practical
joke, the Trojan Horse.
Only I swapped out Silly String for
Broadswords and laughter for murder.
Okay.
You guys want a prank?
Let's prank.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
No!
Oh, God! Ha ha ha.
They just put some toilet.
paper in your
yard?
Why would he do this to his mother?
It was an
accident.
Where's fluffy?
I can't find fluffy.
I'll help you find her.
My eye!
Go in the house. Go in the house.
How's it going here?
That looks stupid.
These puppies are making it impossible for
me to stay mad at you.
Stupid, adorable puppies.
Welcome to Awesomeland where the only thing
to fear is fun itself.
Claire.
I know this isn't a Halloween.
You want it, but can you try to sell it?
I'm sorry, honey, I got mad at you and I
upset Amber and all because Ronnie called me
a soccer mom. What is wrong with me?
Nothing. I hate it when people assume things
about me that aren't true.
Like, because I'm pretty, I'm stuck up.
When people do that to me, I'm just like,
shut up, troll. Why am I even talking to
you? Wow.
I do not like being pigeonholed.
It's obvious. Mom, you use Halloween as a way
to show people you have edge.
It's like accountants who buy a Harley.
She's right. Being scary is my motorcycle.
That's my test. Last fall, Ida Mae moved in.
I told you, she's always up there.
Fortunately, the house was right on Claire's
jogging route, so it was easy to introduce
Claire to Ida Mae.
And when I wanted to amp it up, I had Ida
Mae make contact.
Hey! Then this morning, I knew that axe
wouldn't scare Claire. I just did that.
So she'd accused me of not being able to
scare her.
It's all about plausibility.
Damn right it is.
Over the past year, have made joined the
neighborhood association, hung up a poster
for a lost dog, signed up for Meals on
Wheels. They're not bad, by the way.
Also, she got a lot of knitting done.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Claire. Did I scare you?
You did this?
Yep.
How long are you planning?
11 months. Two weeks?
And three days ago, I gave birth to Ida Mae.
Ma'am. Because.
Ida main man.
Oh, don't you dare do wordplay.
Phil.
Sorry.
I was having so much fun.
What? I was wondering what we were going to
do for the next 30 years of our lives
without the kids in the house.
And now I know you're getting twisted, I
like it.
Game on.
Oh, uh.
Game on. What do you mean, game on?
It's game over.
Nope. Watch your back, buddy.
This is going to be so much fun.
Can't we just travel?